é quando me chamaram pra eu vim aqui
falar eu fiquei pensando o que eu vou lá
falar aí eu resolvi falar de uma equação
e tem duas formas de ler essa equação
uma forma da escola eu vou fazer aqui
como é que a escola lei ela intervalo do
espaço de tempo a levar um quadrado
igual a seda bebida que teria levado ao
quadrado - dentro da ética de cheia
delas em beliches elevada ao quadrado
entenderam que a forma de universidade
ele essa equação é tempo é o intervalo
entre dois eventos instantâneos
definidos por uma própria pessoa
isso significa intervalo da matemática a
isso acho que a educação física então o
tempo é definida em função da matemática
que é intervalo esse é um conceito
matemático ou seja nas ciências exatas
o o os eventos pontuais
eu estou na vida vida eu estou na saúde
e quem está observando esse evento é
humano então todas as ciências humanas
da universidade aprendesse a ler com
ações assim a gente teria universidade é
feito hoje
seria muito melhor e pra não ficar minha
fala podia ser isso é ray mas aí a ser
muito curtinha e para não ficar só na
teoria eu vou resolver falar de um
experimento que eu venho acompanhando há
uns 45 anos bem de perto
eu fui alfabetizado por minha mãe em
casa e depois foi estudar na escola de
pescadores na qual não tinha salas nem
séries nem notas
eu estudava o que queria quando queria
eu li uns 30 livros por ano
eu tinha sete anos de idade e o qual é o
maior trauma quando fui à escola
tradicional séries semestres notas nota
me perseguiu até um dia desses e eu vi a
diretora da escola como que o menino não
não está encaixado insere alguma da
escola claro aquela minha escola nunca
séries
isso foi o primeiro trauma que eu sofri
eu fiquei pensando porque a gente
precisa matar porque precisamos nos
adaptar ao cocho tão restrito e limitado
a gente ter natureza
matematicamente também tenha lido na
escola agenda dos naturais
vocês sabem do meu naturais são
infinitos adaptar uma nota e ainda mais
finita ainda de zero até perceberam mas
as notas que me dão e os rótulos de zero
é isso e ainda porque tem só oito livros
por semestre
ao invés dos 30 na minha escola que eu
que escolhi o que lê e me respondeu
sempre assim
isso é para você ser alguém na vida você
tem que se especializar e procurar
números mais altos possíveis
isso lhe garante uma vida e alguém que
você vai deixar de ser ninguém
12 anos entrei na escola técnica e por
uma técnica mais rápida e fiquei ali e
mais tudo piorou com o tempo porque ao
procurar as melhores de se dizer que
tenho que procurar fica perto do nota 10
que você procurava isso união stress e
diziam quando você conseguir essas notas
você vai ser alguém na
vida e recebeu a recompensa no final do
curso o melhor estágio na melhor empresa
de daqui de pernambuco
e nessa época e até meu nome no jornal
estudante da escola técnica aceito para
trabalho na empresa x
aqui também tem regras e não posso nem
falar o nome da empresa e até hoje sai
notas assim por aí que eu ganhei turnos
diários de trabalho o salário eu
trabalhava de onze da noite às cinco da
manhã porque nessa melhor empresa ela
não podia parar de manhã que ter alguém
à noite consertando e isso me fez pensar
ainda
se eu sou nota perto de 10 e tô aqui
coitado meus amigos que remotas 2 e 3
onde eles estavam e isso me perseguiu na
cabeça porque eu fiquei nessa empresa
por dois anos e toda vez que eu acordava
às 15 16 horas que eu e 2007 da manhã
sabendo que ele estava voltando da praia
ele não tenha conseguido estágio jogando
bola bronzeados saudáveis e olhar meus
colegas de fábrica
sabe que eu via um monte de gente de lã
bronze de lâmpada florescente já vi uma
pessoa com bronze de lâmpada florescente
branco reluzente e aí eu ficava pensando
pra que essa corrida toda uma corrida
biológica e social que nem davi nem
contra entende muito - gilberto freyre
isso me perturbava lembre se a minha
leitura na escola esteve perto do golo
por muito tempo e me disseram aos 19
anos que para sair dessa vida eu poderia
tentar a universidade a universidade lá
se escolhe se estuda o que se escolhe
questiona se o mundo que resolve se a
favor da sociedade e as questões
filosofais da vida
sei lá que eu vou e na universidade ou
se ilusão que em controlar uma escola
com séries notas professor não deixava
eu queria eu tenho que ler oito livros
por ano 4 no primeiro semestre quatro
segundos e obviamente tem que pra mim
isso é uma surpresa eu vinha de uma
escola de 30 livros e ir pra mim e que
não era o universo da universidade e não
os oito livros e ainda pior e pior um
pouco mais e melhor por outro sentido as
notas na universidade era de 0 a 1000
por que os estudantes os professores
alguns deles ainda bem
davam notas com duas casas decimais
entanto em uma escala de zero a 1000 e
não mais de 0 a 10 na escola então
pensava ou essa deve ser a liberdade que
eles falam
e aí vi vivi na universidade até que
conheci três professores fantásticos um
físico se de araújo que estudava
espelhos dinâmicos para mover objetos
lembra-se da equação se você lê isso só
como uma escola
você vai embora se você lê isso como
veneno que é o espelho de nome que move
o bis e objetos e vou traduzir um pouco
e objetos com luiz posiciona os espelhos
e os objetos se mexe
esse cara mudou a regra do universo isso
se é a universidade e aí fiquei
estudando conhecer e aprender com se de
que as regras do universo estão em
constante escrita e matemática lembre se
eu tinha 30 livros de matemática e
passei dois anos um professor chamado
israel venceu chan estudava curvas
algébricas planas
já havia uma curva plana
se você ler de novo como a escola
você não entende isso que ele está
dizendo a idéia aqui é se eu consigo
modelar uma curva numa no ambiente no
mundo algébrico
ser plana e pior ela pode se encontrar
no infinito
o que decide o que quer dinheiro ensinou
nesse momento que o nosso cotidiano na
verdade é um modelo muito simples da
matemática não tem curva plana só tem
curva curva e aí contra e outro
professor chamado silva e meio da
computação que me ensinou que estudava
um sistema chamado o aqua e esse sistema
hoje não tem mais depois que eu posso
falar os livro direitos autorais
é nesse sistema ele estudava ele dizia
que o tempo é controle do usuário e não
de quem está regendo então ele criou que
naquela época o que era um hipertexto
ou seja a habilidade do leitor que lê
como e quanto ele quer obviamente que eu
fui pra esse projeto e ainda descobrir o
outro problema outra outra grandeza da
universidade que foi o número de 50 0 a
quando você tira 850 todo mundo me
respeita
porque quando você as pessoas tiram
todos os dez e os mil e 900 nas notas e
850 alguém pensa é porque faltou pouco
para estudar mas quando a turma
inteirinha tira abaixo de 500 e você é o
único 850 de 300 estudantes da área 2 e
aí eu li muito sobre tudo nessa época
porque 850 me deixava esse não é um
minuto 50 daquele e aí eu consegui tirar
notas baixas em que as pessoas só sendo
ruim porque de vez em quando a turma
inteirinha era lá embaixo e eu continue
assim e por mais absurdo que possa
parecer isso gerou ainda mais mas ósseo
na universidade ea partir daí é que
começou a minha interpretação daquela
equação para jogar bola correr nadar
tudo dentro da universidade e com o de
uma escola bem séria e ea estas são
fotos
a minha graduação
eu viajei 3.200 quilômetros de bicicleta
pelo litoral do nordeste inteiro em 1 em
salvador de fortaleza a porto seguro eu
conheço cada quilômetro de praia é sabe
que olha que eu fazia isso
no meio do semestre porque é um menino
de 150 e fiz vários acampamentos e
viagens de sete até que um dia conhecer
um homem aqui em buíque interior se
dizia imortal eu fiz hoje ele resolveu
tempo melhor que silvio meira
dez anos depois ele morreu
a universidade pra mim foi essa mistura
de inúmeras oficinas adrenalina
serotonina estudo vivia assim e na
escola fazer algumas provas notas e
embora ea escola não me limitava e assim
eu tenho uma correria de vida mas era
minha correria de vida
eu não estava com isso isso foi até
quando eu recebi um pedaço de papel com
30 anos de idade estava escrito pelo
papel diploma e doutorado na
universidade criada aqui dentro da minha
vida de turnos e pior nessa vida de
todos vocês já perceberam mas só se
viaja no período de tempo predeterminado
e chama as férias e assim vive em quatro
anos da minha vida sem tempo para nada
há nada pior nessa vida sim quando você
precisa ter muitas carteiras papéis
contratos comprovantes de tudo senão
você não é nada e aí continuei nisso até
que o meu relacionamento da época acabou
depois de dez anos
era matemática e aí eu me declarar
incompetente de vez porque eu descobri
que sem competente as pessoas não lhe
procuram quando alguém procura aí você
pode fazer isso não sei isso em qualquer
tempo você podem corrigir isso pra mim
não sei com o pt mas você mora o aluno
de 50 foi mais um pó compacto total o
que aconteceu comigo
sobrou muito tempo e os eventos da vida
eu que controlava aí pra não sair de vez
é da vida eu mantive em fisioterapia ea
terapia era o seguinte eu troquei tudo
por um tempo
joguei fora televisão talvez a pessoa
muito tempo
joguei fora minhas roupas todas fiquei
com duas gavetas e mantém alguns blues
assim as pessoas pensaram que eu sou o
que minimizou a vida e joguei tudo fora
essas bicicletas até hoje eu tenho umas
três mas o dia me lembro delas também aí
deu tempo para tudo e como não queria
morar numa casa de pombos que tem aqui
os prédios cheios janelinha e os pombos
lá dentro como eu queria morar ali eu
fui procurar um terreno que ninguém que
não tem valor comercial obviamente não
tinha dinheiro e aí foi construir uma
casa em cima de um terreno que não valia
nada e obviamente construir a casa
sozinha porque também não têm dinheiro
para contratar quiteto e engenheiro por
quatro anos na verdade até hoje mostrou
ela e como não tinha como um terreno
descampado lembre se ele não tinha valor
de nada eu passei a floresta
dezoito mil trezentos e sete mudas
plantadas em 50 mil metros quadrados
durante dez anos sem competente é massa
o que eu fiz também comecei a fazer
triatlo
eu tenho muito tempo eu percebi que o
triatlo ipc e possibilitar viajar no
tempo
eu saía e quando eu olhava já estava no
porta nem getjar varzim mas de novo no
organismo e eu vivia assim por muito
tempo
até hoje eu vivo assim e aí fiquei
pensando algumas pessoas não percebem
que o tempo na verdade está na sua mente
é você que escolhe perdê lo ou gastá lo
da melhor forma
aí outro dia é numa escola aqui no
campus inclusive três professores me
disseram que passei pesquisador
você deveria ter uma nota muito boa não
curricular é famoso para quem é da
academia esse currículo e que eu nunca
deveria estudar o que eu queria e sim o
que a academia para determinava aí eu ri
comigo mesmo claro uma isso já era tarde
demais para mim a minha universidade não
cabia mais na escola deles e aí há quase
uma década eu sou de ciência da
computação e trabalha com saúde porque o
porquê daquela equação que mostrei os
avanços da saúde são os únicos que a
gente não controla os intervalos de
tempo na nossa vida a gente não controla
a gente pode gerenciar o intervalo entre
eles e aí comecei a estudar essa questão
só mose malária chikungunya porque eu
estudasse saúde
eu dava mais tempo as pessoas vão ter
que se preocupar em cuidar das suas e aí
prêmios 48 estudantes em mestrado só
isso é muito ruim pra academia só 84
foram premiados e ministério da saúde em
2003 a 2006 tecnologia e sabe que eu fiz
para eles pensem premiados
simplesmente não deixei a escola
trabalhar eles
hoje eu tenho feito isso e encontrei
alguns parceiros para fazer isso também
e como na casa e na floresta eu fui com
a universidade que ninguém queria
ser professor de lá sabe o terreno vazio
hoje temos um time lá brincadeiras e
precisam pular e sabe aconteceu a gente
começou a tap a a escola igual a gente
tá pia a vida e se achar em branco
trabalho o que eu tenho feito hoje em
dia nada só tentando a escola não
atrapalhar meus colegas guarda rural
eles até ganhar um selo treinamento dos
bons
a gente tá enrolando bem o sistema e
agora agora estou aqui pensando se eu tô
na universidade na escola aqui porque eu
só eu falo e vocês não porque eu tenho
que falar em 18 minutos